let's go to our next caller from the
nine one eight area code caller from
nine one eight who's this what's on your
mind today yeah this has been um my
question is what is your take on like
the national debt is it like something
that we should be like worrying about is
it really like this big deal and was
Obama like at fault for like almost
doubling it or it even doubled okay yes
so here's the thing this is a good and
I'm not trying to put you on the spot
Ben can you explain to me the difference
between the debt and the deficit I think
you explained at one time and I may be
wrong isn't the deficit like we're we're
like taking money from and the debt is
just like that's good enough okay so
this is my point Ben and and listen I'm
not calling you out or anything like
that you're President Obama reduced the
deficit which is the yearly amount by
which our expenses exceed our revenues
so you can reduce the deficit but if
it's still positive you will grow the
debt because the debt is the
year-over-year accumulation of how much
we owe or are owed so number one to
really have a conversation about this
we've got to understand that distinction
the difference between the deficit and
the debt the debt went up under
President Obama as it has under as it
did under george w bush and and for the
most part the deficit just goes up i'm
sorry
the debt goes up now I made the mistake
however the amount by which it went up
was reduced under President Obama so to
your question should we worry about the
debt it's not that we should ignore I
don't know of any Democrats Democrats
who say ignore the national debt but the
point is we have to consider the
national debt in relation to the total
size of our economy for example because
the bigger and bigger our economy gets
you can maintain a growing national debt
that is the same percentage of the
economy so that's just some of the
context that's often missing from the
conversation
so do you pay off debt to prosperity no
there's no economic indication that just
starting to aggressively pay down the
debt is going to drastically improve the
economy there's other actions that can
be taken to improve the economy should
we ignore the fact that the United
States deficit spends no it shouldn't be
ignored but we shouldn't allow
Republicans to start holding everybody
hostage over it if that makes sense
yeah so you wouldn't say Obon is at
fault for like it going up and well
again it depends what your expectations
are Obama reduced the deficit so he
slowed down the increase of the national
debt it's I don't think it's realistic
to have assumed that Obama could have
single-handedly gotten us a surplus
right I mean a lot of that is way bigger
than than any one president all right
Ben thanks so much very much appreciate
the call